صلاح يغير التاريخ في انجلترا وامبابي
يحقق رقما قياسيا خارج كره القدم وكره
النهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا تخطف الانظار
هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
دخل محمد صلاح تاريخ الكره الانجليزيه من
اوسع ابوابها اذا اصبح النجم المصري
الهداف التاريخي لنادي ليفربول على مستوى
البريميرليج بوقع 129 هدفا صلاح وصل الى
هذا الانجاز بعد تسجيله هدفين من اصل سبعه
اهداف سجلها ليفربول في شباك الغريم
الازلي مانشستر يونايتد في ليله قاسيه على
جمهور المانو الرجل الذي كسر صلاح رقمه
نجم ليفربول السابق روبي فاولر شهد على
انجاز صلاح من المدرجات بل وهنئه في
تغريده على تويتر ليرد عليه اعلامي مصري
بصفه ظل يو ار جا دعو جميل
ومن انجلترا ننتقل الى فرنسا حيث وصل
النجم باريس سان جيرمان كيليان مبابي الى
مئه مليون متابع على انستجرام ليصبح
الشخصيه الفرنسيه الاكثر متابعه على مواقع
التواصل متفوقا على كريم بنزيما
في لقطه طريفه وسعيده بالنسبه لجمهور
يوفنتوس رفض النجم الايطالي اليساندرو ديل
بيرو الامساك بوشاح نادي روما وذلك خلال
الصوره الجماعيه في الاستوديو التحليلي
الخاص بلقاء روما ويوفي بالدوري الايطالي
اللقاء انتهى لصالح روما
نشرت شركه اديداس اليوم صورا لكره النهائي
دوري ابطال اوروبا للموسم الحالي الكره
التي لاقت اشاده كبيره من متابعي اديداس
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي استلهم
تصميمها من النقوش التركيه نظرا لان
النهائي سيلعب على ملعب اتاتورك الاولمبي
في العاشر من يونيو المقبل